So he consulted a Green Beret on the most respectful way to do this,
and he decided to take a knee during the national anthem.
He lost his contract with the 49ers,
he was blackballed by every NFL owner,
he was criticized by millions
and even the president of the United States
decided to insult him.
It may be decades before Colin Kaepernick is adequately respected for his courage,
so our team decided to do this.
Now anyone that walks by Trump Tower can see Colin Kaepernick take a knee
in augmented reality,
and there's nothing they can do about it.
(Laughter)
Representation matters.
Serena Williams proved to the world
that a black girl from Compton can dominate a sport
that's traditionally played at exclusive country clubs.
Let's celebrate her now.
Jackie Robinson.
He broke the color barrier
and empowered many black athletes to play in Major League Baseball.
We're going to take this monument of him and put it in Ebbets Field
so that anyone can see him swing for the fences
in Ebbets Field in Brooklyn.
With augmented reality,
we have the power to tell stories in public spaces that need to be told.
The achievements of people like Frida Kahlo, Audre Lorde,
Toussaint Louverture,
Madam C.J. Walker --
this should be common knowledge.
Our vision is a "Pokémon Go" for a contextualized history.
Augmented reality can also be used as a tool to support organizations
that are fighting against systemic oppression.
In 2019 we will release our free smartphone app
with augmented reality monuments and content.
You can take your smartphone and hold it over any one-dollar bill
and see a scene in augmented reality
that illustrates the injustice of cash bail.
You can then click on the screen
and be directed to the donation page of The Bail Project,
a fund that raises money for people who cannot afford bail.
With augmented reality,
we the people have the power
to highlight the narratives of the oppressed
when institutions refuse to do so.
We can use this tool to highlight the systemic implications
of erasing someone's history.
And more concretely,
we can use this technology as a way to support initiatives
that are fighting against systemic racism.
With AR, we have the power to reimagine a world
that prioritizes justice over oppression.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)